[Music]
anyways hello hi josh and ryan what's
your name my name is samantha hey
samantha nice to meet you both you as
well um
my question is a bit abstract i just
want to excuse stick it up here but um
throughout your minimalism journey you
say you discuss that
it can and will change
is there an intentional way that you
reassess your values how do you know
when your values change
um
yeah yeah over time it's a pretty broad
question what are you what are you
struggling with right now with respect
to your values um i mean when i started
out on this minimalism journey yeah i
had like
not a vision board but you know i wrote
down what i value like health yoga all
those things and i guess i haven't
come back to that and i was wondering do
you guys have a do you reassess every so
often or is
is there a certain way you look and and
the reason you haven't gone back to it i
think i know it but maybe you can tell
me
i guess it's working so far
because it is working so far or maybe
some things are not working yeah
um
i mean it never hurts to double check on
your values i guess
sure yeah
yeah i mean i think the problem we often
run into with these types of things is
we feel as though we're supposed to make
you know whether it's a goal spreadsheet
or a vision board they're functionally
the same thing
or you know write down all your values
or we have a values worksheet in the
book to better understand your values
the main reason that we have that is
there are four different types of values
you it's like building a house you have
surface i'm sorry you have foundational
values everyone has a similar foundation
in their house
but above that you have structural
values everyone's house looks a little
bit different on the interior so
everyone has different structural values
beyond that you have surface values
that's those things that make life
interesting or beautify your house the
big problem is the fourth category
though we have these imaginary values
and that's how we spend our day every
day we spend our days doing things that
we know aren't that important to us
but the truth is they are the most
important things to us however you spend
your 24 hours and this isn't a value
judgment it's not a morality claim
it's merely that if i spend an hour
after this scrolling through twitter
that's fine
but it is that in that moment is the
most important thing to me now i can say
something else is just like i can say my
health is really important to me but
when i weighed 100 pounds more than i
weigh now it obviously wasn't it was
hypothetically
important to me but that was a lip
service value
i can tell you this at the beginning of
each year my wife and i we sit down and
we just sort of like look at each
other's values because i find that the
people closest to me it's good to
understand what they value
so i know how to best interact with them
and understand what they appreciate so i
too can appreciate it and then of course
at times we'll have conflicting values
and just like we have conflicting
personalities ryan and i are radically
different
from each other but that's what makes an
uh a relationship interesting if we were
carbon copies of one another then we
wouldn't need both of us on stage today
although i would kill for that hair
oh man we had a we did a show in atlanta
and there's a comedian named jp sears he
was our guest and he said
he said uh he said something someone
asked about beliefs and values and he
was like um because i think you should
have your beliefs
you should hold them tight
you should love them but don't believe
your beliefs
and
you know as an antidote it is funny but
there's a lot of
depth in that statement because
anything that we hold on too tightly
sometimes it will drag us
and we have to be willing to let go
and that you know when i talk about uh
the willingness to let go of being a
superpower it really is and that's not
just with our things but it's also with
some values and beliefs and yeah i think
it's totally appropriate
to look at those every once in a while i
know for me if something's off if i'm
feeling
anxious or depressed or whatever it is
you know i can quickly in my mind look
at those foundational
values and ask myself
okay like where how full
are each of those buckets
and then you know the least full bucket
if that makes sense like that's that's
what i'll focus on you know maybe one
day i look at those i'm like oh this
buckets are full but something else is
still off
i mean
having the the willingness to let go the
willingness to walk away from
a value or even a belief it gives me
the room to um to explore really so yeah
i think we should always be exploring
and
yeah of course things change
you know i'm thinking about um we have a
friend named derek sivers he wrote a
book called hell yeah or no
and
one of the things he talks about was
quite often our identity gets tied up in
these things that we say we value or
things that we value once upon a time so
when we talk about our values those
foundational values they tend not to
change health
relationships community contribution
things like that you know it's half
dozen to a dozen
foundational values but the structure
can change from time to time as you
change your life maybe you have a
radical life change like when i walked
away from my corporate career my
structural values changed quite a bit
but the values that tend to change are
those surface values we repaint our
homes the problem is we're constantly
trying to change the surface
when
it's like we're trying to paint a
burning house
like oh this will fix it
but we don't actually figure out what's
going on
inside
the the structure
and part of that is our identity we
cling to the things that we used to find
valuable those things that were surface
values before so
derek he was a full-time musician i
think for 20 years
and he went around and you play
festivals and
and that's how he earned a living
but then he left that behind you know
over i was probably two decades ago now
or 15 years ago
and yet he still like kept some of the
instruments and he had a piano and a
guitar and some recording equipment
which would all be fine
but he wasn't using any of it and he
realized like oh i say i value being a
musician
but i don't in fact it stresses me out
thinking i might have to go back to that
and it was incredibly freeing the day
that he put it all out for free on you
know craigslist wherever the website was
and people just came over and picked up
the guitar and all the stuff
and now it's in a home where it's
actually being used and he's no longer
tethered to that old identity
thanks for your question thank you thank
you appreciate you being here
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free